the writing is impeccable on Silicon
Valley but you also have a terrific cast
such a funny group I get the sense you
must get along because you're funny guys
I know a few of you and and have talked
to you it's a good group isn't it it's a
great group I've known some of those
I've known TJ and Camille for a lot like
you know ten years Zac for a while
Martens knew but he too much to my
personal life but good god he's a good
belt he's a good boy yeah but yeah it
gets pretty ridiculous on set we're very
comfortable with one another and so yeah
there's a little bit of because it's
nice because that's a little bit what
it's like here we get comfortable we
start messing around and then if someone
came in from the outside world and so
what we were up to they might be oh yeah
well let's I mean maybe you guys
challenge HR as much as we do because
Zac of the creepy little devil he'll
come up behind you and go he'll say
something like you can't expect to leave
that kind of meat around and not not get
not how to get bitten and then he'll
crap like your hamstring be like I'm a
Wolverine like you know TJ and I and
pretty much all an elementary school
kids around the world will go you know
credit or debit and swipe a button or
debit do you know about because I didn't
know about it it's like it's like what
cool people do it's like you just what
you swipe someone's swipe a but you
swipe the the fissure that separated one
buttock from the other yeah yeah like
and you want to get in there like you
know where the poop
in an upward or downward y'okay you go
you try and make it as creepy as
possible me go hey credit or debit oh
and you do it over pants relax baby
super pants your money yeah and then and
then what I do you know because I have
prison mentality and I I approach any of
that kind of stuff with just 100%
aggression I turn around and grab the
junk and say cash
the response since that's oh what a
funny joke it's 100% true yeah and will
and will be like we you know because
we're so we get so giddy you know we'll
be like literally at the end of a take
we're walking away and we know that when
we round a corner everybody's gonna
start grab each other's nards
and Amanda cruise like this looks like
so much fun like cash me and I was like
we can't cash you you're a woman yeah
that is across the line no you can't do
that
we Bitcoin her we just grab her